[Music]
to
[Music
] europe was not made we had
the war europe will not be done all at
once nor in an overall construction
it will be done by concrete achievements
first creating  a solidarity
of sorrow
the president still 2001
before proceeding to this discussion
the council or indeed will have the
German Italian Belgian
Dutch and Luxembourg governments answering
immediately to the French shovel two
months after they meet in Paris
to draw up a draft treaty  and ten
months later at the quai d'orsay
the six powers sign the treaty
[Music]
the community has a parliament it is
the common assembly which holds its
meetings in strasbourg the president of
this assembly is a former president
of the italian council
sir  bella sir shovels there
who speaks to you now with the conviction
that despite the obstacles and
prejudices despite the hesitations and the creams
the will will prevail over the routine on the
10th  february 1953
a first train of european coal
followed three months after a first
train of steel freely crossed the
borders abolished
the common market in coal
and steel became a reality
[music]
resist
diarra not lose the  constitutive session
of the assembly of the european communities
he we listened to be tempted
the assembly had to proceed will have
the election of the two rappers officially
preceded nisa precise windy program within
community europe deadlines and we
would dream roberto this moment and  we
invite submarines the presidency
[Applause]
we proceeded to the election of
eight vice-presidents
[Music]
I must point out that the assembly
formulated an opinion on the subject of the seat of the
European institutions
the decision  of this difficult problem
does not belong to the assembly
it is urgent however to find a
solution but the essential objective
nevertheless remains the establishment
ever closer fruitful
collaboration between the executives
the parliamentary committees and
the assembly itself
yeah  realization of an
important plan for the construction of
workers' houses
[Music]